it's a guidance to the pious and then I give you immediately a parallel verse what's
the parallel verse my Mercy encompasses all things everyone loves this verse continue it though I'll
prescribe it I'll ordain it for those who have tawa all right and I I've told
you this story many times before that I was at a a talk and the professor
gets up there one of these Prof Islamic Studies professors and someone raises a and says
what do you say about very good people who aren't on your religion right very good
people who aren't of your religion so she's a the question has already judged them as
being good she she's already made herself a judge it's built in the question and the
guy he's being political so he says the Quran says my Mercy encompasses all things now
long young little boy just a 14 15y old boy he goes to him could you
finish what the verse says finish what the verse says I shall ordain it on the
people who have tawa resist Temptations humble yourself accept what you may not like okay all
of this is the only way to get this mercy so it encompasses all things means
what means for example uh there are enough lexuses for all of us doesn't mean you're
going to all get them right it's going to go to the one who can pay
for it so my Mercy it encompasses all things that means no one's too big for
Allah's mercy no sinner is so bad that he can't get Allah's Mercy however who's going
to get it those who have tawa what is really tawa the fight to resist
Temptations all right that's the the real Crux of what tawa is okay and then it's
described who are the people of tawa they pay the the prescribed arms they believe in
our Revelation they follow the messenger okay uh the they Command right forbid wrong
uh makes good things lawful make bad things unlawful relieve burden
okay he's saying what this is what the prophet does but this is what we're supposed
to do too